anybody who comes to see our show in the
studio live knows there's a guy who does
comedy to warm up the audience before we
start taping well this is interesting
the guy who used to warm up our crowd
back in New York in the early 90s
remember this guy a long time ago he
sometimes stops by here in LA to pump up
the crowd for old times sake
wait Stanley's family members here today
Stanley from the early 1990s who used to
warm up our crowd Stanley been our
friend for 25 years well he dropped by
today he was hanging out backstage I
thought it might be fun to just bring
him out let him work his old magic back
on the crowd for old times sake please
welcome Stanley Park well yeah
make some noise make some noise
I know Cody okay is this working to work
it I don't know if the mics work it
makes some noise alright now what is Dan
like gonna do okay Stanley what do you
do dan was sounding good to see you what
do you what brings you back to town
nobody did I hear you're going to New
York I don't want to ask you to bring me
back I want my old gig back make some
noise make some noise can you bring me
back now i Stanley we already have a
warm-up guy he's very good and he's
gonna bring him out for our New York
show oh come on how can you turn down
the stanley magic watch this counter
watch what i do what should i do how you
guys doing all right
make some noise Conan they're revved up
they're jazz totally anybody in the
world can ask a crowd how you doing I
don't I don't get it yeah but watch this
I can do I can do one-on-one crowd work
watch this name watch this Oh God ma'am
hi what do you what do you do for a
living
good for you I have not worked in over
eight months due to severe hypertension
make some noise
[Applause]
family you're supposed to do so she will
say dental assistant or hygienist
angeles's ate something kind of funny
you're not supposed to just say you're
depressed and make some noise it's
ridiculous I don't think we want that
kind of thing for in New York shows I
rift with her it was great you didn't
rest that's right riffing alright we'll
watch this I got a big New York closer
watch this this is gonna be great and
the Big Apple watch this
who wants that's enough Stanley they're
warmed up Thank You Stanley you can do
it you gotta bring me quality ladies
you